there's breaking news courtesy of nfl
media and this is a stunner to me two
years after washington literally got
adrian peterson off the couch in late
august and he came in and had a thousand
yards for them and by all appearances
was going to be the top tailback at
least the early down option with darius
geiss gone nfl media says adrian
peterson future first ballot hall of
famer has been released by washington
can you believe that shireen adrian
peterson out stunner
stunner it's an absolute stunner but it
just tells you that they don't think he
has anything left at this point mike i
don't think he's going to break emmitt
smith's
rushing record for career rushing yards
but yeah i i'm i'm very surprised at
that i thought at least he's a guy you
keep around in that running backs room
even if he's not playing every single
down you keep him in there to groom your
younger running backs he's been very
good at that but uh apparently they
think he has nothing left and and now
they're moving on from him that that's
the surprise of the day so far and i
think we're going to see more of those
in the next two days
he's going to leave behind 750 000
in dead money uh they avoided two point
two five million dollar salary that
would have become fully guaranteed week
one
uh
and and and uh i you know we're kind of
scrapping the outline here and focusing
on this adrian peterson news because he
talked not that long ago about the bond
he feels with the washington fans and
how he wants to be there for several
more years and he does have his sites
set on emmett smith's all-time rushing
record and you know i i believe that
frank gore
and adrian peterson could both end up
with more yards than emmitt smith the
question is who will give them the
opportunities to get the carries and the
yardage necessary you need a team that's
willing to employ you and now that
adrian peterson's cut that abruptly that
quickly he instantly becomes a free
agent i just wonder where he's going to
end up and let's put him on the list
with earl thomas and jamie clown he has
potential future faces right
and i think you also list seattle i mean
they have this problem at running back
we've seen them bring in these veteran
running backs and work out these veteran
running backs and uh
constantly because of the injury to
chris carson and the other injuries
they've had
with penny and some others with their
starting running backs and so i think
you also have to put seattle on the list
with what they do with veteran players
so that those are the first teams you
immediately look at just because of
their history of veteran players to me
is new england seattle
and i think one of the realities too you
know apparently they feel good about
bryce love right the guy who was on
scholarship last year he had the acl
tear they were waiting and waiting and
they knew when they drafted him this is
a guy who would have been drafted a lot
higher if he was healthy they took a
flyer and and and again because we
haven't had the pre-season
we haven't had joint practices we
haven't been able to see
what these guys can do and maybe bryce
love is a guy they've kind of kept up
their sleeve as a guy who was ready to
take off you don't get rid of adrian
peterson unless you think you have
a replacement unless he really does have
nothing left it really is a stunner
though 35 years old he plans to keep
going and now we'll see where he ends up
and uh it's going to be
maybe the first shot of what will be a
very interesting weekend as the cuts
approach on saturday
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports